So we just learned how to do that JavaScript token
in lexical analysis.
Now we need to know how to handle that special
JavaScript token.type when we're parsing.
Just to review a bit,
this is how we did basic HTML parsing
or our basic HTML grammar.
We say it's a parsing rule, with p_.
This is the kind of thing we're trying to parse--an element--
and then we write down here, the rule from the grammar,
and where we would normally write an arrow, they ask us to write a colon.
So element can be rewritten to word.
And then p[0] is the final parse tree.
And p[1] is the child parse tree.
And we build the final parse tree out of the child parse tree,
growing a bigger tree, over time.
Well--actually, our handling of JavaScript elements is very similar.
We just indicate that an HTML element
can consist of a JavaScript token,
and we build up our parse tree by
noting that it's a JavaScript token
and then including the text.
And you see this word here--JAVASCRIPT--in all capital letters.
Back here, when we were lexing the JavaScript token,
we said: token.type is JAVASCRIPT, in all capital letters.
Those intentionally match.
This is the linkage we're making between the lexer and the parser.
In fact, they have to match; otherwise, it won't work.
So let me show you a concrete example.
Let's say my HTML input is: hello my
and then there's some 'javascript' which says:
document.write (99);
and then "luft ballons".
Let me show you what the Abstract Syntax Tree--
or what the parse tree--will look like for this.
And we'll recall that HTML is a list of elements,
and here we have 4 elements: 1, 2, 3, 4.
The first is the word_element, hello.
The next is the word_element, my.
The next is the javascript_element containing
only the important text--
not all of this tag stuff.
And the last is the word_element, luftballons.
This is the parse tree, a list of HTML elements.
It just so happens that none of these are nested,
but they could have been if there were some tags in here.
And here: 99 luftballons
is perhaps more commonly known as--
in English--as 99 Red Balloons.
It was a protest song, in German,
written around 1983.
Here are, clearly, 99 entire balloons.
It must be that the other 95 are just behind this one--
exactly covered by it.
You believe me, don't you? You totally don't.